>>Hello YouTube I'm Rick Aubry. I run a social
enterprise in the United States called Rubicon
Programs. I teach social entrepreneurship
at the Stanford Patrick School of Business.
I'm here at Davos trying to figure out whether
the environment is going to lose out to the
economy in 2009 in the midst of this whole
global crisis. Just stepped out of a session
with Al Gore where he's of course making the
very important comment that the economy and
the environment are bound together,and that
if we are wise and smart it's not a choice
that has to be made but the two are together.
I'm certainly hopeful myself. One of the things
that we do at our social enterprise is create
big new businesses that will have huge impacts
in the United States, and we're doing one
in waste management arena, in the recyling
of mattresses,and we think that significant
investments may in fact flow so that rather
than landfills getting filled up with such
things mattresses and carpets actually businesses
can get created for homeless men and women,people
who been out of prisons,and other people who
are marginal in the economy. Can in fact get
jobs created through environmental innovations
and through environmental investments in 2009.
So I'm hopeful it's not a choice that needs
to be made. Thank you very much.